PASS TIPPED IN.
THAT WILL BE AN EARLY ICING CALL
JUJUSTOP BY HELLEBUYCK.
NICE SAVE EARLY ON A GOOD LOOK
FROM A LITTLE BANK
PASS BY MANGIAPANE OFF THE NET.
TKACHUK DRIVING THE NET IN THIS
CASE I IE.
NOW BACK TO THE LINE, BIG
ZADOROV WITH A SHOT.
HELLLRST CALGARY FLAMES'
GOAL.
THE CHANCE BY AWAY.
MANGIAPANE PLAYS IT BACK TO
KYLINGTON.
HE SHOOTS!
N.
DILLON DENIED THE N WINS THE DR.
HE GETS THIS PASS HERE FROMMTS .
FOR HIM AND HE KNE.
THE CALGARY ZONE, AND THE
FLAMES' LEAD CUT IN HALF ON A
LAIDDES AROUND THE OTHER SIDE.
UNDETET ZONE.
COUGHED IT UP.
KEPT IN BY
LATESTNOW IT'S STOPPED BY MARKS.
STASTNY GOING TO THE GOAL.
THERE'S THE FRONT.ASTNY AND IT'S
A 2-2 GAME.
COMPLAINING INITIALLY.
ANDERSSON CHECKEDEDR A TERRIFICY
MARKSTROM
EHLERS.
F
EHLERS AGAIN.
ANOTHER SHOT, DEFLLD THE WINNOP.
HE C A LOOK.
TRYING TO GET A PUCK IN SHORT
SIDE AND HELLEBUYCK HUGS THE
POSTAR.
OUTMUSCLES BACK -- MANGIAPANE
GETS IT BACK.
FRONT.OT IN
MONAHAN STOPPED BY HELLEBUYCK!
WHAT A SAVE ON THAT CHANCE.
HE DROPPED HIS STICK AGAIN.
CONNOR SCORES!
KYLE CONNOR A
HUGE WAY.
IT WAS GOING ALL THE
AND THAT SHOULD SEAL IT WITH A
MINUTE TO GO.
ANDREW COPP INTO THE EMPTY NETEO
COPP AND HE MAKES NO MISTAKE.
HEAD UP.
MAKE SURE